الحرية الشخصية الأجنبية هي أمر أساسي بالنسبة
لنا كأميركيين، لا يوجد شيء أكثر
أهمية ولا شيء أكثر قداسة، لقد كان ذلك
عمل دوري الأول للنضال من
أجل ديمقراطيتنا، لا ينبغي أن تكون هذه
ثورة حمراء
لحماية حقوقنا للتأكد من ذلك
يتم التعامل مع الجميع في هذا البلد على قدم
المساواة وأن الجميع يُمنحون
فرصة عادلة لجعل الأمور على
ما يرام ولكن كما تعلمون في جميع أنحاء البلاد يصطف
المتطرفون في مجال المجلات للاستيلاء على
تلك الحريات الأساسية
التي تقطع الضمان الاجتماعي الذي دفعته مقابل
حياتك بأكملها مع خفض الضرائب من
الأثرياء يمليون قرارات الرعاية الصحية التي
يمكن للنساء اتخاذها حظر الكتب
وإخبار الناس بمن يمكنهم أن يحبوا الجميع
بينما يجعل الأمر أكثر صعوبة بالنسبة لك
لتكون قادرًا على التصويت
[موسيقى]
عندما ترشحت للرئاسة قبل أربع سنوات
قلت إننا في  معركة من أجل روح
أمريكا وما زلنا
نواجه سؤالًا هو ما إذا كان
لدينا المزيد من الحرية في السنوات المقبلة أو
حرية أقل، والمزيد من الحقوق أقل،
وأنا أعلم ما أريد أن يكون عليه الوكيل
وأعتقد أنك تفعل
ذلك أيضًا.  ليس هذا هو الوقت المناسب لأكون
لهذا السبب أنا أرشح نفسي لإعادة انتخابي
وأنا أعرف أمريكا
الأجنبية